i'm playing anonymous
i don't know if they're watching the
stream or not
okay so we have
okay so this is kung fu chats it's chess
without turns
but if you move a piece you can't move
that same piece again for a certain
amount of time
ah this is so much fun
[Music]
oh no what's it doing
oh the bishop's gonna hang soon
okay
hey let's go i'm winning all the pieces
okay let's go for the mating attack i
guess oh don't hurt my knight though
i play this move and then this move and
then this move
wow
oh black is a goner and now it's mate
hey i'm gonna win the king i think
actually i'll let the king move
yeah now i take it
hey okay oh so much fun
gg to anonymous
so now i'm gonna play lightning where
it's a bit crazier
okay let's play french salmon
french salmon if you're here you have to
click ready to start
unless you're not ready and then i'll
abort
i think we broke the oh no we didn't
bring them okay
all right
oh this is lightning
oh this is so much fun i'm just taking
all the pieces
why can't i castle
oh
oh it's so confusing
hey i'm gonna win the king okay
oh
it's so fun just without turns you you
really need to like be focused and have
fast mouse
okay who else wants to play can we do
four player let's do four player okay so
if if anyone has an account here just
click the four player pool hey
okay so my first kung fu four player oh
dear
hey okay we're going
i can't take diagonally
oh wow
oh no someone lost our king
how did that happen
oh i can't take pawns diagonally but i
can take other stuff can i promote
oh this is so confusing
don't hurt me
oh no
oh it's so
stressful
watch this watch this watch this
no
can i promote my pawn
oh no i'm in trouble
no
oh they didn't take my king though
wait red we have to team up
green is who's green
i don't know who green is
red if you're if you're listening to me
we have to go after the green king
that's the only way to win
i don't know if we can team up
accordingly
oh what's going on oh i should have
taken the queen
oh no
don't hurt me
now
that was fun though
oh red was gary oh bean muncher good job
bean muncher
how's rough
only 43 of the total cells in your body
are actually a part of you all more than
half of you is foreign bacteria viruses
and fungi oh no
my body composition
thanks for the fun fact
are we ready
okay
click ready to start and then
[Music]
okay
oh this is okay now now let's protect my
king
there we go
let's go
there we go okay
the two are down
no
oh no
hey free queen okay
no
oh can i take the king
yes let's go
i think black had a split second to
get the king out of there
wow gg
easy win
and let me try and make the board bigger
oh this is so much fun hey okay we have
people
hey let's go okay four-player chess time
blue chess
[Music]
don't hurt
me i want to play
i'm kind of going oh red has perished
it's almost checkmate
hey
there we go okay
let's go
i don't know why this is so satisfying
well i gained some rating points too
plus 98 let's go
i mean four player chess without turns
is just
this is revolutionary
this is like the new
fortnight or among us or
i don't know what game is trending these
days
already sorry okay
[Music]
i was a free queen
oh no
there we go
[Music]
there we go
okay no mercy now
wait what
why can't i move
i'm stuck
wait oh it bugged up for a moment
oh no
hey look at that rook it's gonna make a
journey
there we go
plus 77
nice
it did lag a little bit when it lags
like it it stalls for a few seconds and
then it's like a brand new position when
it returns
but the movement of the pieces like it's
much easier to
it feels like pretty clean
[Music]
feels much cleaner than the previous uh
site that i played on
okay one more one more and then i have
to go
[Music]
okay so we have clunker silverback
aeroquil
oh this is frustrating no one else is
ready
okay i'll do one more uh lightning then
i i really have to go soon but it's so
much fun
here we go okay playing clunker
good luck clunker oh the board's set up
wrong again
they're playing akali system
my castle i castle
i castled long even though
[Music]
oh it's so confusing
oh no
here we go
oh
they suck me out
wait what's going on here that's meat
that's a cool mate actually
when the rook was here and the king was
here in the nights where
were being the bread of the sandwich
a
rich much